how to win at rock-paper-scissors with
expert advice from dr. Ben Dyson
rock-paper-scissors is an ancient game
of cunning and chance if only there was
a way to improve those chances turns out
there are a few key strategies the game
is mainly about predicting and reading
your opponent's so what if you could
predict their firsthand research has
shown that there is a slight preference
for people to begin by playing rock
there are different theories about why
it could be because it is mentioned
first in the name of the game or it
could be because rock is similar to a
fist which seems powerful so if we know
that it gives us an edge just play paper
[Music]
research shows that people who lose a
hand tend to change so there is a
reasonable chance that our opponent will
change to scissors or paper that gives
us our second edge just place scissors
and we should either win or draw but
this isn't an exact science what if it
doesn't go to plan and your opponent
wins perhaps they know a bit of game
strategy too if we lost the previous
hand then our opponent might reasonably
expect us to switch to something else
this gives us our final edge surprised
them by sticking with our previous
choice
hopefully they'll switch expecting us to
switch and it should improve our chances
the less predictable you are the better
chance you have of winning
[Applause]
you